et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
gabriel attal bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être la galerie à la tall porte parole
du gouvernement et vous êtes surtout là
en tant que soutien du candidat emmanuel
macron ce matin merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour
l'invitation on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes point intervient en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre redon
du groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france mais jean fabbri son
jour pour jour bonjour thann et gabriela
talent on va parler de l'ukraine
évidemment puisque on a entendu ce
week-end le président américain joe
biden qualifié vladimir poutine de
boucher emmanuel macron a réagi hier il
dit qu'il n'aurait pas employé ces mots
est ce que joe biden prend le risque de
créer une escalade dans ce conflit je
n'ai pas à qualifier les propos du
président américain
ce qui est certain c'est que ce qu'on
recherche c'est évidemment une sortie du
conflit le président la république se
mobilisent pour cela évidemment ça veut
dire toujours qualifié ce qui se passe
les exactions qui sont commises par les
troupes russes dire les choses en face
aussi à vladimir poutine c'est pour ça
qu'ils échangent régulièrement continuer
à mettre la pression sur la russie
notamment en matière économique puis
continuer à apporter un soutien aux
ukrainiens en termes humanitaires et en
termes militaires une fois qu'on a dit
ça nous on ne cherche pas une escalade
nous ce qu'on cherche encore une fois
c'est une forme d'apaisement et la
sortie du conflit c'est pour ça que le
président de la république a tenu les
promesses que là il avait rappelé est ce
que là s'il prend le risque ils veulent
le ruiner les efforts de dialogue encore
une fois je veux pas qualifier les
propos des uns et des autres ce qui est
important encore une fois c'est de
chercher toujours dans nos mots et dans
nos actions la sortie du conflit vous
n'êtes pas de gouvernement français vous
il vous a pas échappé que côté américain
ils ont ils ont regardé très très
rapidement les propos du président
américain la semaine dernière il ya eu
un couac ou pas selon vous je ne sais
pas encore une fois ans je pense que il
faut en permanence quand on est
responsable politique dans un tel
conflit chercher dans nos mots et dans
nos actions ce qui est utile à la sortie
du conflit ce qui est utile à gentil du
conflit c'est d'agir encore une fois en
mettant une pression sur la russie pour
que le coût de la guerre augmente et
qu'à un moment la russie soit contrainte
de revoir ses plans et ses calculs et
d'y renoncer ce qui est utile à la
résolution du conflit c'est de soutenir
les ukrainiens qui ont fait le choix
courageux et héroïques
de résister en leur apportant un soutien
en matière humanitaire et en matière de
défense voilà moi je pense qu'il faut se
concentrer là dessus un mot quand même
sur emmanuel macron la situation se
qualifier de catastrophique situation
humanitaire qualifié de catastrophique
la mario paul-emmanuel mâcon doit
s'entretenir avec vladimir poutine pour
organiser des couloirs humanitaires
quand doivent-ils se parler et à ce que
les conditions de sécurité peuvent être
garanties pour assurer l'évacuation
décidée écoutez que je crois pas que le
rendez vous était fixé mais c'est
aujourd'hui ou demain j'imagine puisque
le président vendredi a dit qu'il
parlerait dans les 48 72 heures
effectivement on a préparé avec la
turquie avec la grèce une opération
humanitaire pour évacuer des civils je
crois qu'il le reste cent cinquante
mille personnes aujourd'hui à marioupol
qui est une ville de quatre cent mille
habitants habituellement il y à des
habitants qui veulent fuir parce qu'ils
sont sous les bombes parce que les
images qui nous arrive de marioupol sont
des images de dévastation absolue parce
qu'ils la guérilla urbaine se poursuit
parce que les bombardements se
poursuivent aussi et donc il faut
permettre l'application du droit
humanitaire et permettre de protéger les
civils donc très concrètement nous avons
fait cette proposition aux opérations
humanitaires il ya eu un travail qui
s'est tenue ces derniers jours avec les
autorités ukrainiennes pour la préparer
et maintenant il faut convaincre la
russie vladimir poutine d'accepter cette
opération humanitaire c'est pour ça que
les chefs d'état vont échanger très
prochainement pour qu'elle puisse
aboutir nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
le siège soit levé que l'aide
humanitaire puisse arriver que les
civils qui souhaitent pouvoir fuir
puisse le faire un dernier mot sur ce
qui se passe en russie le groupe mulliez
refuse de quitter la russie malgré les
demandes du président ukrainien au
groupe mulliez chez auchan décathlon
leroy merlin le ministre des affaires
étrangères craignent un appel au boycott
d'auchan compenser nous on a fixé avec
les partenaires européens avec les
alliés un certain nombre de sanctions
quand on fixe des sanctions on cherche
encore une fois un objectif qui est de
renchérir le coût de la guerre on n'a
pas demandé aux entreprises étrangères
ce soit la france où les autres pays de
quitter la russie en revanche qu'on leur
a demandé est ce qui est appliqué par
les entreprises françaises c'est de ne
pas s'engager dans de nouveaux
investissements en russie à partir de là
ça devient une décision de chaque
entreprise il ya des entreprises qui ont
décidé de se retirer de la russie
on s'y est pas opposée pour certaines
entreprises là l'état français et au
conseil d'administration s'y est pas
opposé à ce choix je pense qu'elles font
ce choix en se posant plusieurs
questions d'abord les questions
opérationnelles des questions d'image de
réputation aussi évidemment et donc il
appartient aux entreprises de faire le
show est injuste que les ukrainiens le
ministre des affaires étrangères écrit
appel au boycott d'une entreprise
française je suis encore une fois moi je
vous ai dit je pense que ma
responsabilité de porte-parole du
gouvernement ça n'est pas de qualifier
des propos des uns et des autres il faut
beaucoup de sang froid dans cette crise
et je pense que notre responsabilité à
nous c'est de rechercher ce qui est
efficace et de pas voir entrer dans ce
type de débat ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il ya des entreprises françaises qui
sont en russie qu'elles font des choix
qu'elles doivent appliquer les sanctions
qui sont fixés et elles le font pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles les avaient
même devancé ce qu'ils avaient annoncé
qu'ils auraient pas d'investissements
supplémentaires avant même on leur
demande dans le cadre des sanctions et
ensuite elles prennent leurs décisions
en compétences moi je veux rappeler que
les sanctions qui ont été prises à
l'encontre de la russie elles produisent
des effets que les sanctions massives
qu'on a pu appliquer parce qu'il ya une
unité européenne parce que les alliés
aussi nous ont suivis elles ont permis
quoi elles ont permis que le rouble
chute elles ont permis que la bourse de
moscou soit fermée pendant plusieurs
semaines elles ont permis des oligarques
voient leurs actifs en dehors de la
russie gelé ou saisies elles ont permis
des prises de position du coup que ce
soit dans l'église orthodoxe en russie
que ce soit le numéro 2 gaziers russes
des prises de position contre ce conflit
est donc ce qu'on cherche nous encore
une fois c'est que le coût de cette
guerre soit tellement élevés du fait des
sanctions que ça dure entre guillemets
du fait de la résistance des ukrainiens
que les autorités russes finissent par
se dire finalement ça nous coûte trop
cher il faut qu'on revoie nos calculs on
espère que ça arrivera on pense que
c'est possible encore une fois parce
qu'on voit l'effet sur nos sanctions
c'est pour ça que les sanctions doivent
être appliquées il ya des propos du
président de la république qui ont
inquiété les françaises sur la crise
alimentaire sans précédent c'est ce
qu'il a dit la semaine dernière on a
conclu forcément la hausse des prix des
matières premières allaient entraîner
des hausses de prix est ce que si
emmanuel macron est réélu il y aura des
aides pour aider les français à faire
face à ces hausses de prix est ce qu'on
peut envisager un chèque alimentaires
non mais bien sûr mais d'abord on a
annoncé un certain nombre d' aide
indépendamment de l'élection
présidentielle et un plan de résilience
qui a été annoncé par le premier
ministre qui comporte une dimension
agricole il faut bien comprendre que la
russie et l'ukraine sont parmi les plus
grands exportateurs mondiaux de blé il
ya d'autres produits aussi qu'ils sont
très concernés l'huile de tournesol par
exemple on a une chance en france c'est
qu'on est indépendant en termes
alimentaires ont produit notre
alimentation on a cette indépendance
cette souveraineté agricole c'est une
vraie chance et on le voit c'est même un
luxe quand on compare avec d'autres pays
dans le monde il ya donc ces tensions
d'approvisionnement au niveau mondial
sur cette question du blé par exemple et
donc il ya des pays très concrètement
notamment d'afrique subsaharienne qui
risque une pénurie et on sait que les
conséquences de ça c'est des drames
humanitaires c'est des famines et c'est
potentiellement des bouleversements
politiques majeures donc il faut agir à
l'international est en crise migratoire
par exemple car c'est évidemment
possible et donc c'est pour ça que le
président de la république a lancé un
mouvement à l'international pour obtenir
plusieurs choses d'abord qu'on puisse
libérer des stocks pour faire baisser la
tension sur les marchés au niveau
international ensuite qu'on puisse avoir
un mécanisme de solidarité un peu comme
on l'a fait sur les vaccins pendant la
crise qu vite vous vous souvenez on
avait mis en place un dispositif kovacs
au niveau européen pour doter des pays
pauvres en vaccins avec une solidarité
on veut faire la même chose s'agissant
du blé par exemple et c'est ce qui a été
lancé et puis enfin c'est investir pour
augmenter les capacités de production
des pays notamment africains qui encore
une fois ne sont pas autonomes
aujourd'hui en matière alimentaire ça
c'est pour l'international mais c'est
très important pour le niveau est bien
le cheval pour la france on est
producteur de blé est donc encore une
fois ce n'est pas une question de
d'approvisionnement ou de pénurie en
revanche on voit que les coûts
augmentent parce que la demande reste
réel au niveau mondial et que les
approvisionnements mondiaux du fait de
la situation en ukraine et en russie se
réduisent et donc ça peut avoir un
impact sur le prix à la fin notamment
parce que les éleveurs par exemple ont
besoin pour nourrir leur bétail de ces
matières premières et donc ce qu'on a
annoncé dans le cadre du plan de
résilience c'est par exemple une aide de
400 millions d'euros pour notre
agriculture pour faire en sorte que pour
les éleveurs les agriculteurs on puisse
compenser cette hausse des coûts de
production pour que ça se retrouve pas à
la fin sur la facture des français donc
c'est des mesures fortes supplémentaire
pour le porte monnaie des français bah
on a pris un certain nombre d' aide sur
la question énergétique moi je veux
rappeler la blottière et sur la question
alimentaire le président de la
république a dit qu'il voulait aller
vers ce chèque alimentaires et donc
effectivement dans les prochains mois si
les français nous en donne la
possibilité on ira vers ce chèque
alimentaires notamment pour les ménages
les plus modestes pour qu'ils puissent
se nourrir compris en local autre
question sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est
les prix à la pompe évidemment qui
inquiète là aussi les français le
gouvernement qui a annoncé une remise de
18 centimes sur le continent par litre
sur ses prix à la pompe que ça soit bien
clair cette baisse elle sera appliquée
dès vendredi dans toutes les stations
service sont oui absolument 1er avril
c'est ce qu'avait annoncé le premier
ministre c'est un système qui permet de
compenser en partie la hausse du coût de
l'essence pour les français on a déjà
pris un certain nombre de mesures je
vais les rappeler l'indemnité inflation
tous les français qui touchent moins de
2000 euros ils sont 38 millions ont reçu
cette aide exceptionnelle de 100 euros
on a relevé le plafond de l'indemnité
kilométrique pour les français qui
doivent beaucoup roulé notamment dans le
cadre de leur activité professionnelle
je pense par exemple aux infirmières
libérales qui doivent faire leur tournée
on sait qu'il ya un dispositif de frais
kilométriques qu'il aurait appliqué on a
relevé les barèmes pour compenser là
aussi cette hausse du prix de l'essence
et donc on a pris cette mesure pour
quatre mois de baisse de 18 centimes à
la pompe de ristourne de 10 centimes à
la pompe pour un litre d'essence on a
aussi demandé aux distributeurs
d'essence de participer à l'effort vous
avez par exemple total qui a annoncé
qu'ils ajouteraient une baisse de 10
centimes en plus des 18 centimes de
l'état aux livres d'autres distributeurs
qui ont annoncé aussi des mesures tout
ça doit nous permettre de tenir jusqu'à
ce qu'on met en place un dispositif qui
est véritablement ciblées vers les
français qui en ont le plus besoin c'est
à dire ceux qui roulent beaucoup qui
travaillent qui gagne peu on espère
pouvoir le présenter dès vendredi
rudy vous êtes vous allez faire votre
plein dans n'importe quelle station
service vous avez à bâtir un système
pour cela et on apporte des garanties y
compris pour des stations par exemple
qui ça devient un peu technique mais qui
remplissent leurs cuves moins
régulièrement que les grandes stations
parce qu'elles ont moins de
fréquentation certains dispositifs
d'avancés de trésorerie qui sera fait
pour qu'elle puisse appliquer cette
baisse dès le départ la crise oui autre
invité surprise de cette campagne cette
nouvelle vague de couronnes à virus on
voit le réapparaître le masque dans
plein d'endroits les écoles les
entreprises est-ce qu'on a allégé
dispositif trop tôt est ce que vous
envisagez de revenir à des mesures on a
demandé beaucoup d'efforts aux français
depuis deux ans avec des mesures et je
pense que si les français ont respecté
les règles qu'on fixe est et ont fait
ces efforts c'est parce qu'il savait
quand on prenait des mesures quand on
mettait de nouvelles règles c'est est
impérieusement nécessaire du fait de la
situation à l'hôpital et non concédées
toujours engagé à lever nos mesures dès
lors que la situation de l'hôpital se
serait détendu et elle s'est beaucoup
détendu ces derniers mois c'est encore
détendu sur la semaine passée et
aujourd'hui 150 patients de moi en
réanimation qu'ovide que la semaine
dernière on est repassé sous la barre
des 1500 je crois et donc c'est normal
et c'est légitime et c'était attendu par
les français on assouplit c'est qu'on
lève nos mesures dès lors que la
situation à l'hôpital s'est amélioré à
temps ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
constate en france comme peu près
partout en europe un rebond de
l'épidémie je crois pas qu'il soit lié
au fait qu'on ait assoupli les mesures
il avait d'ailleurs commencé un peu
avant par ailleurs on le constate dans
d'autres pays en europe y compris des
pays qui ont gardé des mesures qui ont
gardé par exemple le port du masque
partout et donc là ce qu'on dit aux
français c'est oui on a levé ces mesures
on a eu raison de le faire on revient
pas dessus mais il faut évidemment
garder une vigilance notamment quand
vous faites partie des français fragile
je pense aux français âgés voire très
âgées il faut évidemment faire attention
quand vous allez dans des lieux où il ya
beaucoup de monde c'est vrai que porter
le masque ça permet quand même de vos
protégés faire un deuxième rappel quand
vous avez plus de 85 ans c'est aussi
protecteur parce qu'on sait que même si
ce variant omicron et beaucoup ange rue
en train de beaucoup moins de forme
grave au global pour des personnes très
fragile très âgées il peut rester
dangereux donc on a cet appel évidemment
à la responsabilité et à la vigilance et
oui on a maintenu notre calendrier de
levée des restrictions d'usagé rythme au
sein des millions de français vont se
rendre aux urnes à ce que le masque sera
obligatoire dans les bureaux de vote
pour l'instant je crois pas que ça a été
fixée ou alors l'information m'a échappé
mais vous l'envisagez fait la remontée
des mois je ne veux pas dire que exclure
des choses par principe aujourd'hui j'ai
pas connaissance qu'on ait pris une
telle décision mais évidemment pas dire
qu'elle sera pas pressé non évidemment
les élections se tiendront on a vu qu'on
a pu tenir des élections quand il y
avait des vagues très forte de coheed
avec un protocole sanitaire des
protocoles seront oui bien sûr enfin la
direction locale donc là on peut revenir
à un protocole un peu plus que j'en ai
encore une fois j'ai pas d'informations
à vous communiquer sur ce sujet là mais
un mot sur la corse oui la situation
s'est à nouveau tendue qui avait atteint
ce week-end en corse après là diffusion
notamment d'une vidéo de militaires sont
en la marseillaise pendant les obsèques
disons colonna
vous avez réagi comment assez assez
réaction d'hier soir notamment de ces
feux de vendée des compagnies on a vu il
ya effectivement à nouveau des tensions
très fortes qui se sont heureusement en
fin de soirée je crois vers 23h arrêtés
qui ont cessé et je crois qu'on déplore
un bilan au global de 7 blessés légers
évidemment amener ces rs a6 ouais je
veux c'est crs et les manifestants
évidemment nous notre souhait c'est que
l'apaisement revienne le calme que
l'ordre revienne pour qu'on puisse
échanger
gouvernement exécutif corse sur toutes
les questions relatives à la corse cette
ville et cette vidéo vous choque ou pas
quelle vidéo cette vidéo qui a été
diffusée c'est de serrer chantant damas
eye et un jeu j'ai pas de j'ai pas vu
pour jeunes entendu parler des eaux non
authentifiée
je sais par an dans une caserne mais
mais les obsèques d'yves en colonne à 17
ce qui est important c'est que on puisse
avoir le calme avoir l'ordre
l'apaisement pour pouvoir avoir cette
discussion ces négociations pour pouvoir
avancer sur tous les sujets qui
préoccupent et qui a serré aujourd'hui
vous voyez que les tensions et continue
et finalement c'est possible aujourd'hui
c'est impossible à quelles conditions
est ce que ces personnes un nouveau pas
c'est possible parce que il ya eu une
rencontre entre le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et
l'exécutif corse s'est rendu sur place
pendant près de trois jours est qu'à
l'issue de ces trois jours des changes
il ya eu une forme d' accord de méthode
qui a été signé entre les deux et que on
a du coup un calendrier de discussions
de réunion de travail sur les questions
institutionnelles sur les questions
économiques corse
devaux qui doivent démarrer je crois au
début du mois d'avril et qui vont se
poursuivre un mot juste sur les cabinets
de conseil avant de parler de la
compagne d'emmanuelle macro emmanuel
macron a redit hier qu'il voulait la
transparence sur les cabinets de conseil
privé en rien un rapport du sénat qui a
beaucoup fait parler près d'un milliard
qui ont été dépensés l'année dernière
pour des recours à ces cabinets de
conseil privé est ce que dans le
prochain quinquennat vous vous engagez
avoir moins recours à ces cabinets de
conseil qui l'ont d'abord on n'a pas
attendu le prochain quinquennat pour
fixer un cadre je rappelle qu'en 2018 on
a rappelé à tous les ministères le cadre
sur les marchés publics sur les règles
etc il ya eu la crise sanitaire où il ya
eu une augmentation du recours au
cabinet de conseil s'est terminé à vous
comprenez que c'est simple c'est une
réalité on était dans un contexte de
crise historique où vous avez besoin de
mobiliser toutes les forces ça s'est
fait dans tous les pays est important
c'est de revenir à un
recours plus normal de rythme de
croisière au cabinet de conseil et donc
on a ces dernières années oui on n'a pas
attendu le prochain quinquennat puisque
ma collègue émilie de montchalin
ministre de l'action la transformation
public qui en charge de ce sujet là a
annoncé sur 2022 une baisse de déjà de
15 % des dépenses liées au cabinet de
conseil maintenant moi je vous le
rappeler les cabinets de conseil ça fait
très longtemps que l'état ya recours en
france que des collectivités y ont
recours en france des régions des
mairies des départements que tous les
pays du monde y ont recours l'important
c'est que ça se fasse avec mesure et que
surtout ça correspondent à des besoins
des pouvoirs publics sur des compétences
sur des missions par exemple qui
n'existe pas dans l'état ont fait
beaucoup pour avoir des compétences des
missions supplémentaires dans l'état n'a
fait une réforme de la haute fonction
publique pour diversifier les profils
les parcours dans la haute fonction
publique pourquoi des personnes il vient
du privé puissent venir travailler dans
la fonction publique a porté aussi leurs
expériences leurs compétences mais quand
vous quand vous avez un projet une
mission qui nécessitent d'adjoindre des
experts qui ont une expérience qui
peuvent apporter quelque chose à l'état
oui faut y avoir recours moi je fais pas
partie de ceux qui considèrent que
l'état par principe et omniscient
omnipotent évidemment à dire on a vu
dans la crise sanitaire aussi qu'en
dehors de l'état il pouvait y avoir des
initiatives privées il pouvait venir
renforcer l'efficacité on a vu par mme
sur les vaccins tous ces sites qui ont
été mis en place vite ma dose kobe de
liste etc qui permettait à partir des
données et des informations qui ont été
communiquées par l'état de rendre plus
accessible un certain nombre de choses
aux français je trouve ça très positif
quand vous avez en dehors de l'état des
personnes qui viennent de s'engager pour
l'intérêt général un mot sur une réforme
qui a fait beaucoup parler une des
mesures du programme des manuels mâcon
qui fait beaucoup parler c'est la
réforme des retraites le chef de l'état
qui dit qu'il passera l'âge légal à 65
ans sur une durée de neuf ans et
progressif il a bien venu expliquer mais
un mot sur le calendrier il sa présente
les construit les doigts est ce que ça
fait partie de vos priorités est ce que
ça sera présenté d'ici l'été ce qu'a dit
le président de la république plutôt le
candidat emmanuel macron en l'espèce
c'est qu'il souhaitait après son
élection si les français est lui en
donne le mandat lui font confiance
lancer des discussions des négociations
avec les partenaires sociaux je crois
pas qu'il ait fixé de calendrier fixe
dans l'émission à laquelle il anticipé
la rentrée c'est qu'ils parlent de
l'année ce qu'il voulait essayer puisque
les discussions puissent commencer
maintenant vous savez si vous voulez
discuter de manière ouverte et
constructive avec les partenaires
sociaux fixer d'ores et déjà une borne à
la discussion je suis pas sûr que ça
permette cela donc nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que cette réforme elle
puisse être faite on pense qu'elle est
nécessaire pour le pays moi je veux
rappeler quand même qu'on a un système
qui est financé par des actifs qui
travaillent qui payent la retraite et
des pensions des retraités qu'on a de
plus en plus de retraités parce que
l'espérance de vie s'allonge et que donc
on a progressivement en déficit qui se
creuse de notre système que si on fait
rien à la fin on pourra plus payer les
retraites et donc il ya trois choix qui
sont possibles pour rééquilibrer les
choses soit vous baisser les pensions
des retraités on refuse de le faire soit
vous augmenter les cotisations les
impôts sur ceux qui travaillent pour
pouvoir financer les pensions des
retraités on refuse faire aussi soit
vous demandez aux personnes qui
travaillent de travailler un peu plus
longtemps évidemment pas tous dans les
mêmes conditions évidemment en tenant
compte de la pénibilité des combats là
dessus ça ça on n'a pas très bien
compris de quelle manière il sera tenu
compte de la pénibilité mais c'est
précisément ce qu'on doit construire
avec les partenaires sociaux c'est pour
ça qu'on veut une discussion une
concertation avec eux dans ce n'est pas
fixé il doit y avoir une réintroduction
des critères de convenir et une en bas
parce qu'on ne veut pas c'est recréer
des régimes spéciaux vous même les
supprimer et notamment supprimer les
deux principaux régimes spéciaux ratp
edf on a déjà supprimé celui de la sncf
pour les nouveaux entrants on va faire
la même chose pour les nouveaux entrants
à edf et à la ratp parce que c'est pas
normal on considère que un chauffeur de
bus à paris par rapport à un chauffeur
de bus dans d'autres villes françaises
alors qu'ils font le même travail qu'ils
ont la même rémunération celui de paris
puisse partir jusqu'à cinq ans je crois
avant les autres c'est pas juste je
pense pas que les français soutiennent
ce type de la pénibilité c'est la
discussion avec les partenaires sociaux
rien et fouillée sur l'application en
revanche qu'on dit c'est qui sera tenu
compte de la pénibilité qui sera tenu
compte des carrières longues ce que vous
avez des personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler à 17 18 19 20 ans évidemment
il faut qu'elles puissent partir avant
les autres et donc il y aura cette prise
en compte pour faire pour leur permettre
de partir avant la noce et sur une
question celle des collectivités
emmanuel macron et l'a3 mais rien dire
qu'il a besoin d'eux les collectivités
quelle contribution vous attendait
d'elle pendant le prochain quinquennat
est qu'elles seront mises à contribution
à hauteur de combien la première
contribution on attend des collectivités
et des élus c'est qu'ils participent aux
grands chantiers qui ont été ouverts par
le candidat emmanuel macron quand on
parle de revoir complètement la façon
dont fonctionne notre école pour que ça
soit plus efficace c'est soit ça réduise
encore davantage les inégalités
évidemment on en a besoin des élus
locaux quand on parle de la santé de la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
évidemment qu'on a besoin de travailler
avec les élus locaux quand on parle de
renforcer l'insertion dans l'emploi des
français en créant france travail c'est
à dire en faisant en cassant les silos
qui existe aujourd'hui évidemment que ça
nécessite de travailler avec les élus
locaux serbie mais cela vient de notre
parti est ce que vous allez je vais
venir le mot d'ordre de notre campagne
c'est avec vous avec vous c'est
évidemment avec les français c'est aussi
avec les élus c'est avec toutes les
forces vives de la nation on doit
construire les solutions et c'est ça
qu'on le croyait que le pré le candidat
emmanuel macron a dit dans sa lettre a
rappelé dans sa lettre aux élus ensuite
parce qu'il n'est pas question
d'économie dans la lettre est ce que oui
ou non on s'assied dans la lah
d'économies de fait dans la lettre et
dans le programme ce qu'on dit c'est
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une trajectoire de
dépenses qui est fixé par l'état par la
sécurité sociale par les collectivités
locales et que ce qu'on souhaite pour
l'état pour la sécurité sociale pour les
collectivités locales c'est
qu'évidemment elle soit contenue modéré
voilà et parce qu'à la fin il ya un seul
contribuable qui paye il ya une seule
dette à rembourser et donc c'est ça qui
a été rappelé par treize ans la commune
a tout entendu laurent saint martin
devant des élus par les un chiffre de 10
milliards oui
tout en rappelant tout en rappelant
qu'il y aura la sanctuarisation des
dotations aux collectivités locales vous
savez moi je me souviens en 2017 on
faisait campagne pour emmanuel macron et
on avait on s'était engagé à ce que les
dotations aux collectivités soient
sanctuarisés on avait à ce moment là je
me souviens des élus qui le disaient on
a vu une saignée dans nos dotations dans
le quinquennat qui vient de s'écouler
est ce que vraiment vous allez tenir
votre engagement on a tenu notre
engagement il a été tenu et donc qu
emmanuel macron dit que les dotations
seront sanctuarisés mais vous demanderez
économies mais on demandera à l'état à
la sécurité sociale aux collectivités de
faire un effort non pas de dépenser mois
mais deux que l'augmentation des
dépenses se fasse de manière modérée
voilà c'est quand même
c'est un effort qui paraît tout à fait
soutenable ses congénères question fasse
pas au détriment au contraire de la
qualité de service pour les français
dernière question sur ce qui s'est passé
hier lors du meeting bien évidemment il
est au trocadéro pendant 10 secondes
des soutiens de derrick ces mots
scandant macron assassins devant des
images de victimes notamment du
terrorisme eric zemmour dit ne pas les
avoir entendus vous en pensez-quoi
savez moi je soutiens un candidat
emmanuel macron qui a toujours rappelé
dans ses meetings c'était le cas en 2010
est je pense ce sera encore le cas il ya
un meeting important à à paris qui se
tient samedi prochain qui a toujours
appelé à la bienveillance qui a refusé
qu'on siffle donc ont eu ses adversaires
et là vous voyez un candidat qui laisse
des militants proférer des propos
absolument insupportable à l'encontre
d'un autre candidat je pense que c'est à
ça qu'on juge aussi les hommes quand ils
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
qui est une fonction dont moi j'ai pu
voir aux côtés du président de la
république combien nécessite du calme du
sang-froid et oui de la bienveillance
soyez soir eric zemmour ne tient parole
n'a pas d'autorité sur ses militants
soit ils cautionnent ce type de propos
dans les deux cas c'est assez inquiétant
sur la capacité à sur sa capacité à
exercer les fonctions président de la
république
pour voir écouter ça c'est les français
qui en décident je sais les français qui
votent et qui décide qui est le mieux
placé pour présider notre pays mais bon
moi je rappelle encore une fois que nous
on s'est toujours battu et on continuera
à se battre pour la bienveillance en
politique parce que la réalité c'est que
quand on tient des propos inacceptables
sur un candidat qui appellent à la
violence quand on laisse tenir des
propos inacceptables sur un candidat qui
appellent à la violence faut pas
s'étonner derrière qui est de la
violence contre les élus faut pas
s'étonner derrière qui est de
l'attention qu'il puisse y avoir des
agressions et donc il faut jamais
laisser passer ce type de propos merci
cavaliers à la tâche merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin en
tant que soutien du candidat emmanuel
macron
[Musique]